actually eric weinstein came out with
the theory of everything
i mean that came out he's been working
on a theory of everything in the physics
world
called geometric community and then for
me from computer science person
like you stephen wolfram's theory of
everything of like hypographs is
super interesting and beautiful but that
not from a physics perspective but from
a computational perspective i don't know
have you paid attention to
any of that so again like what would
make me pay
attention and like why like i hate
string theory is
okay make a testable prediction right
i'm only interested in
i'm not interested in theories for their
intrinsic beauty i'm interested in
theories that give me power over the
universe so
if these theories do i'm very interested
um can i just say how beautiful that
is because a lot of physicists say i'm
interested in experimental validation
and they skip out the part where they
say to give me more power in the
universe
i just love the um yo i want i want i
want the clarity of that i want 100
gigahertz processors
i want transistors that are smaller than
atoms i want like power
that's uh that's true and that's where
people
from aliens to this kind of technology
where people are worried that
governments like who owns that power
is it george hearts is it thousands of
distributed
hackers across the world is it
governments
you know is it mark zuckerberg there's a
lot of
people that i don't know if anyone
trusts
any one individual with power so they're
always worried
it's the beauty of blockchains that's
the beauty of blockchains
you